recibido entre abucheos el coche del
presidente francés se detiene para
visitar una escuela en los barrios del
norte de marsella una de las zonas más
desfavorecidas de francia esta escuela
como muchas otras de la ciudad está en
mal estado y emanuel macrón ha prometido
ayudar al plan del alcalde para
renovarlas este es el gimnasio de la
escuela y puede verlo por usted mismo en
qué estado se encuentra a pesar de
nuestros mejores intentos de limpiarlo
en previsión de la visita del
presidencias a ocho meses de las
elecciones presidenciales marsella está
en el radar de macrón en el segundo día
de su visita de tres días dijo que era
el deber de la nación ayudar a mejorar
las condiciones de la ciudad plagada de
pobreza y delincuencia derivada de las
drogas
hablamos mucho de la urgencia de la
situación de seguridad algunos dirían
demasiado porque no es nuevo pero nunca
deberíamos acostumbrarnos pero si ve
hacia la situación en los barrios de
marsella se trata de una lucha contra el
narcotráfico que debemos combatir pero
excepto debemos llevar a cabo una
verdadera casa una política de acoso a
los traficantes tanto aquí sobre el
terreno como hasta los jefes de la red
de tráfico extranjero
de macrón dijo que además de los 150
millones de euros ya prometidos a la
policía de la ciudad 200 agentes
adicionales serán desplegados el próximo
año y se instalarán quinientas cámaras
de vigilancia a los barrios más
peligrosos de marsella también prometió
más dinero para la renovación de
viviendas y hospitales y la ampliación
del transporte público macrón espera
evitar la competencia de su contrincante
presidencial de extrema derecha marine
lepén que se espera se haga su campaña
con una plataforma de ley y orden así
como de la izquierda que pide más
recursos para los servicios sociales